we are back with the fox news alert and
this is a not a good number the december
jobs report just released the united
states adding just under 200 000 jobs
last month
economists were expecting 422
000
but in the good news department the
unemployment rate has fallen to
3.9 percent and we're under 4 that's
good
for analysis let's bring in stuart
barney host of varney and company on fox
business get started in 28 minutes
stuart this this number is terrible it's
less than half what they were expecting
it's a big miss that's a fact 199 000
new jobs in december not a good number
at all and remember this please the
numbers were accumulated in mid-december
and if you think about it that was
before the omicron rolled and surged
through the economy so this does not
reflect the weakness in the economy
after the omicron surge it reflects
weakness before the surge in other words
by the time we get the next set of
numbers we'll probably see even an even
worse jobs picture because omnichrome
will be that a factor in the jobs report
steve the thing to remember about the
job market at the moment is that it's
extremely tight it's great to be a
worker in america today there's lots of
jobs available and wages are rising but
the other side of the coin is simple
inflation you've got six percent
inflation which is wiping out the wage
gains of the average worker in america
today not a great employment situation
at this moment steve
no kidding and of course stewart as you
know before the uh christmas holiday the
binding administration was quite
defensive and they essentially said
ahead don't worry joe biden has saved
christmas saying that there were no
supply chain issues
i think the white house said 90 of the
shelves were filled well 10 of the
shelves then were not filled and that
you know the supply chain disruption one
of the reasons why bed bath and beyond
which is a great store is going to wind
up closing 37 stores in 19 states
because they simply have been able
unable to
get stuff on a lot of shelves they were
reorganizing their company but the
supply chain issues made it much worse
well the store closures were announced
some time ago they're part of an overall
plan but the supply chain crisis really
hit them hard because right before
christmas they could not restock their
shelves they were one of those companies
where you walk in and you see some empty
spaces on the shelves there they are
supply chain victims actually and you
know the supply chain isn't improving
we've still got 100 ships floating
around off the shore of the ports of los
angeles we've still got a chronic worker
shortage we can't deliver goods to the
stores we've got a supply chain crisis
that's still in progress it has not been
fixed
yeah um meanwhile you know as as a lot
of people and we look at the jobs number
and it's terrible and now for people who
are thinking about refinancing or buying
a new home
uh the
the uh mortgage rate has gone up as of
yesterday it was 3.22 this is the
highest it's been in two years right it
is yes it is um and this really hits
hard at first time home buyers
that the proportion of first-time home
buyers as a of the overall market
is really way down there only about a
quarter of the buyers of homes today are
first-time buyers that's very unusual
simply put they're being priced out of
the market the median price of a sold
home at the end of last year was four
hundred and four thousand dollars that's
about twenty percent higher than it was
at the beginning of last year that
prices first time buyers out of the
market and with mortgage rates rising to
what three and a quarter percent roughly
speaking that raises your monthly costs
that puts more and more people out of
the market
rising interest rates are the big
problem today in america and that's
because of rising inflation which is
perhaps the biggest
problem facing all of us
you know and and these numbers are
facing joe biden in the administration
because
this is a midterm election year and he
would not like to lose the house and the
senate but they're on track to it looks
like
because when you look at the number of
jobs
the inflation whether it's store
closures or what we were just talking
about right here with home mortgages the
rates going up that impacts people
in their wallet and they don't like that
well you see you can see it every day
inflation is something which you can
actually see i don't want to go off on a
tangent steve but you remember those
rotisserie chickens that you could buy
in a supermarket
you know about what six months nine
months ago i could buy for 5.99 what a
bargain you know what it is today 8.99
that's inflation you can see you can
feel and you know it's not doing you any
good a small example but you can stretch
that across the whole raft of things
that we have to buy with its eggs or
cheese or beef or model pay the rent or
electricity bill it's all going up we
feel it we see it and it's not going to
do the president much good
listen i'm sorry that you have to eat so
many rotisserie chickens i'm going to
send you another copy of my wife kathy's
cookbook okay stewart please thank you
all right
watch stewart he's coming up in 22
minutes over on fox business thank you
sir